i did that with my clients a lot so a
lot of them would come home from work
the guys say and and their wife would
meet them at the door and it'd be a
fight right away
you know and it's a clash there because
he comes home and he's tired hungry he's
worked all day and he's hoping that you
know he gets welcomed when he comes back
to the home but then the wife is at home
and she's been with the kids all day and
she's tired and hungry and she's hoping
that when he comes home he'll show her
some appreciation for what's happened
today and then they clash and then they
both have problems to discuss because
they've had their troubles during the
day and so then every time they get
together
they're not like it's a bit of a fight
for 20 minutes and then the whole
evening is screwed
and so then you think okay
here's the deal
it's knocking the door will open okay
you get to pick
how what happens when you come home
but you have to figure out what it is so
now this is the deal
you treat yourself properly
you imagine coming home and it goes the
way you want and need it to go
okay
what does that look like
you get to have it but you have to know
what it is
what does it look like
and you think okay i want to come home i
want to be happy about coming home i
come home
i open the door i say hello honey i'm
home
my wife says hi it's so nice to hear
your voice she comes up she says
hi dear she gives you a hug she says how
was your day
and you say well we'll sit and talk
about that how was your day
well we'll sit and talk about that do
you need something to eat
probably
let's go sit and talk about our day it's
like that sounds pretty good okay
that sounds pretty good might not be
perfect it sounds a hell of a lot better
than what we're doing now so how about
we go
talk to
we'll go talk to your wife and say okay
this is what's happening when i come
home i would like it to be better
what would you like to have happen
if you could have what you wanted and so
she sits down and she thinks okay if he
comes home what do i want to have happen
and then now you've got two visions and
you say well what would you like and
you listen and she says
what would you like can you tell her and
then you think okay now can we bring
these visions together
so not only do we both get what we want
but because we've brought them together
we even get more than we want well who
wouldn't agree to that unless they were
aiming down and that's so exciting it's
not a compromise it's a union of ideals
that's even makes a better ideal and
then you get to come home and then then
there's another rule that goes along
with that which is
please dear have the grace
to allow me to do this stupidly and
badly well i learned at least 20 times
yeah
and all give you the same leeway and
then we'll practice stupidly for 20
times and we'll talk about it and then
maybe we'll get it right for the next 10
000 times yeah right
and you can do that with your whole you
can do that with your whole life and you
can do that with your kids and you can
do that with your family like it's not
easy but you can do it's a lot easier
than the alternative
you